you don't find Kathy attractive no I
fine I'm not gonna tell my nine months
pregnant wife that I find her
replacement objectively attractive just
like I'm not gonna tell my two-year-old
daughter that violent video games are
objectively more fun
it's true but it doesn't help anybody
boyfriend because he's kind
of let's do it
No I um well I'm not gonna I'm
I'm not gonna move in with anyone unless
I'm engaged
am I not proposed to you yet
oh no well
that's coming
oh right now
I'm not gonna do it right here that
would be rather lame
okay so then when
Pam I'm not gonna tell you I hate to
break it to you but that's not how that
works oh right yeah
wait I'm serious
it's happening okay and when it happens
it's going to kick your ass Beasley
so
stay Sharp I've been warned
I am not kidding
got it a week after we started dating
oh it's white we're so close just buy us
a few more minutes
well they just called me in for an
update so I'll call you right back
okay okay great
foreign
hey Dwight uh
send in the subs
oh
I just want to say how happy we are that
all of you are here tonight and I want
to especially thank those of you who
have traveled from far away to be here
with us tonight
especially the Florida cousins who
obviously can't take a hint
four years ago I was just a guy who had
a crush on a girl who had a boyfriend
and I had to do the hardest thing that
I've ever had to do which was just to
wait
uh don't get me wrong I flirted with her
Pam I can now admit in front of friends
and family that I do know how to make a
photography I didn't need your help that
many times and do you remember how long
it took you to teach me how to drive
stick like a year
I've been driving sticks since high
school so yes yes for a really long time
that's all I had I just had little
moments with a girl who saw me as a
friend
and a lot of people told me I was crazy
to wait this long for a date with a girl
who I worked with but I think even then
I knew that
I was waiting for my wife
so
foreign
was it my fault
yeah
he said that you told him how much you
love me
about how you feel when I walk in a room
and about
how you've never doubted for a second
that I'm the woman you want to spend the
rest of your life with
I guess he's never felt that with my mom
even at their best
is it
is it Pebbles from that Beach in Jamaica
oh go easy with the shaking
oh my God
you like it
I love it
yep I do make great Christmas gifts
but I couldn't make that
Jim what's going on where's the
belchnickel
oh my God
what are you doing
last time I saw you were whipping me out
of the building
I can't speak of that
what happened did you miss your bus
was my wife
the new assistant
to the assistant to the regional manager
is
Dwight cash roof yes
I want to kneel for this
and yet the manager for Dunder Mifflin
deals for no man
that's it okay
okay look really really good
[Applause]
okay from now on anyone who needs to
speak to me has got to go through me
first all right
[Applause]
hey
hey all right
what's going on
are you happy yes I'm happy I know I
know that you're like
happy and like you had fun today and
that was fun but what about a year from
now
what what about five years from now bam
yes I'm so glad you're back baby
Daryl and he was talking about the trip
and I just feel like you've given up so
much
my decision
not yours you didn't force me I kind of
forced you did not force me to do this I
don't know how else to tell you I'm
afraid you're going to resent me and I'm
afraid that this is not enough for you
and I'm afraid that I'm not enough for
you
for you not enough for me
you are
everything
there's only a handful of reasons why
someone would ever go to a courthouse in
Ohio and not be charged with a crime to
claim an inheritance from a deceased
relative to obtain a learner's permit at
age 14 and a half instead of 15.
Aaron let me see a birth certificate
sure
there are other reasons to go to Ohio
we're getting married today
so it turns out it's the closest place
to get a marriage license without a
three-day waiting period tell them how
it happened okay so we're going through
all the wedding plans and boy it is
complicated and very expensive very
expensive because you say you want a
small wedding and that's great but then
you have to you can't leave anyone out
no one okay just get to the good part
right oh so this morning we are having
breakfast together
and I just looked up for my cereal and I
said
you know what I want to do today
I want to marry you
I had just woken up I didn't look cute
that's how I knew he meant it
you realize you were taking this now
uh fears
you closed it I closed it yes ah
um congratulations to you thank you oh
thank you very much appreciate it well
done thank you
you know what screw this